for the diamondbacks the right-hander
riley smith very solid and long relief
he has earned the trust and belief from
the coaches and that has led him to this
moment his first ever major league start
as you mentioned pitch really well out
of the bullpen back on the third of
april in relief of caleb smith went five
strong innings in that ball game not
only
cleaning up the mess but saved the rest
of the bullpen
from having to come into the ball game
that one's knocked down by escobar
hey
cabrera is there to pick it up
that's a four five three put out for out
number one just the way you draw it up
yeah
there's a ground ball get down to third
nice play by cabrera turns and fires the
first
and they got him on a really close play
over there castillanos wants to have a
look
no challenge from david bell
trying to get his strength back nice
high hop right to christian walker a
terrific three ground ball first for
riley smith
bottom one the cincinnati reds starting
rotation is not allowed to run in 21
consecutive innings tonight turn two for
jeff hoffman loco gets his started four
for 24 and there's a basin into center
and he's aboard to start us off
castro has seen a few throws he gets
another close play safe
on the slide back in
it looked like le castro was taking off
there that may have happened i think
they got him
it's hard to say where the tag was from
vato but
if he if that tags down right away
in this case vato doesn't have to get
him on the on the hand he can touch him
on the feet
and
oh he came off the bag and they're
challenging and they're going to get him
here what's word on this he's out
they'll take one of the diamond backs
best threats one of the fastest men in
the game off the field here's mike
moustakis usda is hitting 333. seven for
21 a home run three rbis but he's scored
eight times
well hit right field gets down suarez
through second calhoun gathers mustaches
up to second base suarez stop sign from
jr house at third escobar feigns the
throw and a double from mike mustackas
second and third with nobody out nick
senzel big chance two in scoring
position
chip that one into right field that's
gonna get down deep move dupes nobody
suarez scores mustaches to third nick
sanzell with an rbi single it's one
nothing reds little duck squirt going
the other way right here jammed him a
little bit but tried to get his hands in
as best he could and is able to drop it
in there to get a base hit so the reds
hit the ball hard a couple of times in
the first inning this inning they're
getting something to show for and now
jonathan india not your traditional
seven-hole hitter by production second
in the national league in rbis
he'll take it opposite way that ducks
down base hit
mustaches scores two nothing reds in the
second
put the ball in play got a little bit of
a high leg kick timing right on and that
ball gets in on him a little bit
fastball strike three first k
of the night for jeff hoffman is he
check swing appeal
he went
second k for hoffman and calhoun's dumb
yeah second time to third base umpire
who was the home plate umpire last night
edwin moscoso has rung up the hitter the
other was tucker barnhart there are men
at the corner for jonathan india
dropped a shortstop ahmed one eduardo
hey roll it
oh there's the double play ball we just
mentioned riley smith needed it and he
got it in a perfect
spot that get his heel great backhand
pick from his knees india
two down oh that's a nice play
i think that when hoffman double dance
around that ball and run right through
the box he's thinking that's got to be a
base hit right and there's india the
backhanded
picks up some style points
from the first moment of the season
india just
looks like he belongs right i mean
that's cliche look at this play
as drubal a two-time all-star shortstop
with the cleveland indians beautiful
night for baseball there's a drive hit
to right down the line and this one is
gonna go cabrera knew it home run as
jupiter cabrera the dive backs on the
board it's two to one
his second of the year
boy that was loud off the bat 105.8
miles an hour and just a line shot right
out of here
so the dimebags have their first run to
the ball game two aboard 2-1 the reds
lead cno perez in from the bullpen who
throws incredibly hard david peralta is
the hitter
[Applause]
high chopper under india is there shovel
tossed a second everybody's safe they're
loaded now one out for cabrera
it's tied
and this presents another opportunity
here for escobar
up the middle india smothers it wild
throw
walkers home diamondbacks have the lead
he tried the shovel scoop
boy it's been an adventure out there in
the cincinnati infield in the fifth
who runs in bases full two outs now
elise vote up to hit
vote
base hit
peralta's home here comes cabrera
escobar coming around third here's the
throw
vote has cleared the bases
it got out to right center just kind of
died out there long enough for escobar
to race in all the way from first
and it's a five run diamondback fifth
inning
good grinding it back that time by
steven vogt finally finds a hole up the
middle of the field
[Applause]
indian to left peralta's there
riley smith
through six holding a 6-2 lead
there's one for lufkin
high chopper backs up smaller as it
shorts down low throw la castro's aboard
one more time
oh tim lacastro's wearing him out
tonight there he goes le castro is on
the move and that one gets away from
barnhart city with a head first slide
and so that might be some history for
tim lacastre
that is a stolen base he is 28 for 28 to
start his career the longest streak in
the major league since 1951.
[Applause]
walker skies one to center senzelle
getting camped out underneath it he's
near castellanos who backs up here comes
timmy no chance to get him make it 7-2
center field it backs up since elle
still backing up
it's gone edwardo escobar three
consecutive games with a home run
he absolutely clubbed this ball 94 down
below the bottom of the strike zone
right where he likes it
i'll tell you this game is built at the
large part on scouting this is built
in the air to the poles flash down hey
eugenio suarez
delivers a solo shot
it's now eight to three
it's a good sign for suarez really eddie
hitter when you start hitting the ball
opposite of the center of the second
base bag with power like he has
out over the play keeps his head down
what a beautiful swing
bounced over the mound escobar throws
across his body and the diamondbacks
have the win 8-3 riley smith the winner
and his first big league start there you
go